こんにちは
Dr. …
はじめだ
このキャラの存在を忘れていました
サーセン
みなさん世の中には
たくさんのおいしい食べ物があります
なにが好きですか？
たとえば、お寿司
カレー 牛丼 ピザ
カレー 牛丼
ピザ ピザ ピザ
牛丼 牛丼
天ぷら 寿司 カレー
牛丼 天ぷら ×13
そう、牛丼 天ぷら
私 いろんなYouTuberを見て
研究いたしまして
食物を 天ぷらにすると 美味しくなる説
というものが あるみたいなんですけど
その検証が正しければ
私が今からしようとしている研究は
必ず成功するはずだ
名付けて
やっていこうと思う
Dr. はじめ、牛丼が大好きなんだ
ヘドが出るくらいにな
ヘドが出るくらいに好きなんだよ
私 牛丼が大好きなので
その大好きな牛丼を
もっとおいしくなると言われている
天ぷらにすると
史上最高に美味しいんじゃないかという
鬼 太りそうな検証を
今から行う
深夜
3時だ
ちゃんと牛丼をてんぷらにする
工夫をしていこうと思う
移動だー！
まず使うのはこちら
牛丼において大切なのは
牛丼は固形ではありません
お米が牛肉からのだし汁によって
液状化してしまっているので
牛丼屋さんの牛丼とは違って
コンビニの牛丼は
お肉の部分とお米が
別々になっているので
天ぷらが完成してから汁をかけます
なんで まずは肉を載せるだけ
【早送り中…】
こうすることによってこのごはんが
液状化してしまう原因になるエキスを
完成した天ぷらに
後でかけることが可能となった
天才的な…
アイデアだろう？
すばらしい
涙が出ちまうぜ
ここからがまた工夫が必要です
サランラップを使います
このままぶっこんでも
天ぷらにしてる間に
牛丼の固体が分散してしまうので
1回ここに出します
美しい
1度 こいつらを1つにするべきだ
これをなんとか ひとかたまりにします
【早送り中…】
やべ
OK これで完成だ
天ぷらのもととなる
牛丼のかたまりが完成した
あとは揚げるのみ！
【パパパパパパン！】
【キュ】
おいおい なんだこの音は！
【キュキュキュキュ】
【パンパァン！】
大丈夫だ お前は固まっていれればいい
さあ やっていこう
きっとこれがあればできる
「天ぷら粉、水を」
「泡立器でよく混ぜます。」
くっそ 簡単だ！！
まずは鍋にオイルを…
入れていく
なんかもうDr. はじめのキャラが
自分でもよく分かんねえわ
ちょっとまた実験系があったら
Dr. はじめ やっていきますね
いざ 出陣！
【早送り中…】
OK
先に加熱しておこう
さあ 作っていこう
まあ 大体でいいっしょ？
【シャキン】
適量ってのが難しいんだよな
ダマがなくなったから
大体いいんじゃないだろうか
入れていきましょう
あー でも いい いい いい
いけるぞ！
では早速 衣をつけていきましょう
つけた瞬間 崩れたりしないよね…？
OK OK…
OK OK
OK OK!
OK OK, OK!
いい感じではないでしょうか
いける！
さあ あとはゴールを決めるのみ！
行ってこい！
はい！
はっ はっ はっ！
ひっくり返すものが
フライパンのここしかない！
やばい！
あっ あっあっあっ
待って 崩れちゃった！
【鼓動の音】
【悲しげな音楽】
できた！
はい というわけで完成しました
えー 天ぷら牛丼です
惜しかった！
犬のエサやないかい！
あそこで あのボールの形を崩さなかったら
うまくいってた気がしたんですけども
そこでボール状だった牛丼が
割れたことによって
断片的な部分に衣がつくことによって
さらにサクサク感がUPしたという
可能性もあり得る
つまり 成功です！
犬のエサやないかい
いえ だがこれで美味しければいいんです
事前にとっておいた
エキスをかけましょう
もうこれ、たん…天ぷらで
すごい熱いのでかけた瞬間
とろけてしまいますよ
牛肉がビーフジャーキーみたいに
シャキシャキしちゃってますね
部分的にシャキシャキしてて
おいしそうです
では、いただきます
うん、まずい
【ED】
うん、まずいというか
天ぷらじゃなければ おいしいな
あ！
ホットドッグもやってみよ！
あー！なめくじみたいになっちゃった！
衣がポロポロ落ちるんですけど
食べてみましょう
うっま
えー ホットドッグはほんとにやば もう
マスタードがたってる
みなさん ぜひ天ぷらにするときは
ホットドッグをやってみては
いかがでしょうか
牛丼はマジ…
くそまず